und in diese welt die unterwasserwelt
tauchen wir jetzt da sehen wir es
tauchen wir jetzt im wahrsten sinne des
wortes ein und zwar mit jennifer wenth
lange diese außergewöhnliche frau hat
einen neuen weltrekord im apnoetauchen
aufgestellt also tauchen ohne atemgerät
mit nur einem atemzug ist jennifer wenth
latte sagenhafte 93 meter tief getaucht
unglaubliche drei minuten lang hält sie
dafür die luft an weltrekord drei
minuten atmen ja wir können mal die
stoppuhr laufen lassen um das
nachzuvollziehen und wenn sie wollen
halten sie die luft jagen meine damen
und herren während wir ihnen jennifer
wenth land vorstellen
die welt des freitauchen es liegt ihr zu
füßen drei minuten war jennifer wendland
für ihren weltrekord auf zypern unter
wasser 4 stunden am tag trainiert die
essenerin um unglaubliche 93 meter tief
tauchen zu können
[Applaus]
die tiefen jägerin aus dem ruhrgebiet
hält übrigens bereits alle deutschen
rekorde in den offiziellen tief taucht
diszipliniert ist der rekord in der
disziplin no limits führte sie im jahr
2018 auf eine unglaubliche tiefe von 117
metern die grenzenlose freiheit des
meeres und die schönheit der
unterwasserwelt
motivieren die 35-jährige zu diesen
unglaublichen leistungen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
jennifer wenth land kann mit dem gesicht
nach unten im wasser liegend sogar bis
zu sieben minuten lang die luft anhalten
auch wenn sie mehr schon auf haie
gestoßen ist adrenalin junkies am im
freitauchen nichts verloren denn wer
möglichst wenig sauerstoff verbrauchen
will muss tiefenentspannt sein
wir sehen die uhr meine damen und herren
jetzt sind drei minuten rum so lange hat
sie also die luft angehalten werden
verwendet um diese 93 meter zu schaffen
wir haben uns mal umgehört bild reporter
michael engelberg hat im ruhrgebiet
passanten befragt wie lange sie die luft
anhalten können
[Musik]
also ich wäre jetzt vielleicht 20
sekunden schaffen die luft anzuhalten
aber ein essen gibt es eine frau
jennifer wenth plant die ist jetzt frei
und auch weltmeisterin geworden die hat
mit einem atemzug in drei minuten 93
meter tiefe geschafft und jetzt wollen
wir uns hier mal in dortmund um hören
wie lange die leute hier die luft
anhalten können und dann nehmen wir euch
mal mit so wir haben jetzt hier die
stoppuhr und wir haben hier an angel
korte hier herrn gekonnte was glauben
sie wielange können sie nur 30 sekunden
ok dann fangen wir mal an
wir stehen ja mit herrn lernen und jetzt
gucken wir mal wie lange er bernd die
luft anhalten kann
jetzt wehrt super
16 es sieht sehr gut aus herbert leute
schauen so ein bisschen rot an
knapp eine minute 45 heran kommt es hart
im nehmen muss ich sagen
55 56 jetzt haben wir schon 110 geht es
vorbei naja aber 110 ist schon
maschine der bernd
machen sie irgendwie sport oder der spur
kiwi lanka zu denn die luft anhalten da
ich werde das wasser toll aber nicht
einhalten kann ich okay also niki die
kästen eine wasserratte wasserratten
rund
[Musik]
die menschen dass es unbedingt wasser
wartet das stichwort wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellt drei minuten da unten zu sein
und man kann sich nicht einfach
entscheiden dann atme ich jetzt mal
wieder durch wahnsinnsleistung jetzt
sprechen wir mit der jennifer wenth
laden erstmal herzlichen glückwunsch wie
bereitet man sich auf so einen
unfassbaren weltrekord vor
danke schön also einen weltrekord
bereitet man sich ja im prinzip sein
leben lang vor fahren mit allem was man
in seinem leben bis dahin trainiert habe
ich habe dann mit dem freitag und
ungefähr vor zehn jahren angefangen und
2017 habe ich dann intensiver für
wettkämpfe trainiert und ja da haben
wird das training von jahr zu jahr
intensiviert bis irgendwann der
weltrekord für mich in greifbare nähe
kam und ja dann habe ich quasi am ende
steht so vier stunden am tag trainiert
um dann meinen traum vom weltrekord ja
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen frau
wendland wie sind sie dann überhaupt auf
diesen außergewöhnlichen sport bekommen
tja wie kommt man auf so eine sportlich
wird sagen den anfang hat man mir
tatsächlich das unterwasser rugby
spielen gemacht was ich eben auch elf
war vor zehn jahren angefangen habe und
da wird dann festgestellt dass ich ganz
bisschen luft anhalten konnte und wollte
dann eben einfach mal ausprobieren da
ich so wirklich die luft anhalten kann
dann habe ich einen einsteigerkurs
gemacht im freitauchen und dann kam
irgendwann eines zum anderen also das
talent zeigte sich daneben im
einsteigerkurs und das habe ich nach und
nach entwickelt bis es dann im letzten
jahr zum weltrekord greifen und was
fasziniert sie so besonders an diesem
freitag
also was mich fasziniert es zum einen
dass man höchst er bringt indem man sich
vollkommen entspannt
dann ist es natürlich auch wunderschön
da unten in der tiefe allein zu sein und
er diese tiefe zu spüren diesen druck zu
spüren man es halt vollkommen auf sich
selbst gestellt da unten ist es still
und ja es einfach ein ziemlich
befreiendes gefühl finde ich man kann
alles an sorgen einfach an der
oberfläche lassen ich bin wirklich
beeindruckt davon aber so ein bisschen
unnatürlich ist das für den menschen ja
irgendwie schon wie kamen die menschen
eigentlich auf diese ungewöhnliche
disziplin
das freut auch um das geht natürlich
hauptsächlich auch die unterwasserjagd
zurück als ich quasi unsere vorfahren
entweder nach fischen tauchen mussten um
fische zu jagen oder muscheln gesammelt
haben oder andere meerestiere
meinetwegen auch hummer und krabben das
ging natürlich früher hat noch nicht mit
großem schleppnetzen und das war damit
eher unterwasserjagd verbunden und das
waren dann tatsächlich auch die ersten
menschen die sehr lange die luft
angehalten habe was war das schönste was
sie unter wasser erlebt haben
es gab schon tatsächlich einige sehr
schöne momente für mich unter wasser das
war zum einen ein mal tatsächlich das
freitauchen mit heim
vorurteilen und du hast das war wirklich
ein unglaubliches erlebnis diesen
majestätischen tieren die auch einfach
nur neugierig aber total schwierig waren
und dann habe ich tatsächlich dieses
jahr für einige momente beim tief
tauchen unter anderem bei meinen
weltrekord
das da unten sehr sehr viele große
quallen waren das waren zum glück keine
die anbetung sondern mal war dann da
unten ja ein bisschen wie im all und es
würden ganz viele cullen um einen herum
schweben das war auch ein sehr sehr
schönes gefühl vielen dank für diese
schöne einblicke in die unterwasserwelt
viel spaß beim nächsten auftritt in die
tiefe und vielen dank für das gespräch
jennifer wenth leidvolle weltrekordlerin